la première décision aujourd'hui je
pense à prendre c'est de ramener
vraiment cette autorité sur le
territoire bisontin donc c'est d'engager
de suite le recrutement de policiers
municipaux parce que la sécurité fait
partie d'un besoin fondamental de l'être
humain
c'est le renouveau le renouveau en tout
cas deux temps par le candidat à la
candidature que je porte que par
l'équipe renouvelée avec de nouvelles
têtes mais aussi des compétences
nouvelles qui arrivent sur sur le
territoire bisontin par sept équipes
besançon maintenant je n'en vois pas
comme cela aujourd'hui
non je vois pas forcément de handicap
par rapport à cela
non peut-être peut-être l'exigence
allait peut-être deux
engagé métro en réaction par rapport à
d'autres et pas assez pro actif